kalyna bonsoir
le donc la soeur de soan sohane benziane
17 ans brûlée vive le 4 octobre 2002
dans un local à poubelles de la cité
balzac à vitry-sur-seine dans le 94 le 7
avril dernier son meurtrier jamal des
rares 22 ans a été condamné à 25 ans de
réclusion criminelle
alors on va reprendre les choses dans
l'ordre
ça va alors votre père chérif arrive en
france dans les années 50 il a 19 ans il
ne sait ni lire ni écrire mais celle
empêchera pas de travailler durement
toute sa vie
il s'est marié une première fois avec
une femme restés au bled votre maman
kahina vous êtes né en 1981
ensuite ils divorcent de cette femme
parce que les familles ne s'entendait
pas il prend une deuxième femme dont il
a deux filles wahiba et soan mais la
mère de soan meurt d'un cancer
à ce moment là votre père est obligé de
confier ses enfants à des tentes
ensuite troisième mariage dont un garçon
et deux filles voilà alors évidemment ce
n'était pas facile pour votre belle mère
de tout gérer elle devait s'occuper de
détroit des trois premières filles de
mon père plus les trois derniers
s'étaient c'est un peu difficile pour
elle c'est clair alors swan était moins
intéressé par l'école que vous à vous
vous êtes plein de projets ambitieuse
fac d'économie et de communication à
créteil elle quand vous êtes partis
habiter dans votre chambre à la cité
universitaire elle est un petit peu
déserté l'école se valent mais en fait
elle a été mal orienté à la hausse elle
a fait un bep
secrétariat et ça l'intéressait pas ça
n'intéressait pas donc
donc elle a arrêté l'école pour pour en
termine une formation d'esthéticienne
voilà elle elle veut s'en sortir bien
entendu mais pas par l'école elle veut
travailler elle va être esthéticienne
elle est très jolie une petite princesse
elle rêve d'être chanteuse ouais parce
qu'elle elle avait une voix
extraordinaire
elle mais bien la voir fabien way entre
autres alors chanteuse joue
esthéticienne alors elle dit avec des
centres de beauté partout dans le monde
oui parce qu'en fait je me rappelle moi
je suis un c'était un jour où on est et
où on était ensemble
moi j'avais dit que je vais remplacer
claire chazal du réseau
pour moi c'était je voulais remplacer
claire chazal et un
llm disait ben moi je veux être
esthéticienne alors moi un bon j'étais
un peu déçu et elle m'a dit mais
t'inquiète pas moi je serais
je serai esthéticienne mais j'aurai
plein de centre de beauté et les plus
grandes stars viendront chez moi et
alors là après j'ai dit bon ben alors à
la rigueur ça c'est bon ça va
ça c'était comme j'étais allé à
disneyland toutes les deux
ces quinze jours avant le drame ouais ça
dernière fois vous l'avez vu ouais
c'était la dernière fois est-ce que vous
connaissiez déjà mal terreur non jamais
jamais vu non
c'est faux procès ouais
alors soit n'était jamais sortie avec
lui non ouais swan et sortait avec qui
ça donc qui était quand même son grand
amour non ouais 1 mètre 80 mais j'étais
c'était son fiancé était pas sa copine
non il était fiancé
uniquement uniquement
alors l'histoire avec jamal des rares
commence quand on lit ça donc le fiancé
de soan mais un coup de poing à
kheirallah la fiancée de jamal tout
débute
tout débute cette fameuse nuit où où il
ça mais maints coups de poing à la
petite amie de djamel des rares et la
bomba
à partir de là ma soeur elle était
condamnée
parce qu'il avait la honte moi je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé dans sa tête je
peux pas vous dire ce qui a déclenché
cette le fait qu'ils se focalisent sur
ma soeur mais je pense que c'est parti
d'ici coire
alors il décide de se venger il commence
par interdire à votre soeur soan
l'entrée de la cité balzac vous habitez
un peu plus loin 800 matin la cité ben
oui apparemment ils voulaient pas
qu'elle qu'elle s'y rendent quoi alors
que toutes ses copines d'enfance et
toutes ses copines du collège etc
habiter là habite toujours la cité
balzac
là il commence à faire des menaces jamal
des rares dit je vais lui faire la peur
de sa vie et puis une rumeur qui
commence à circuler dans la cité c'est
nono va lui faire un truc de ouf quoi
sans doute parce qu'il avait été humilié
par issa et puis parce que votre soeur
n'obtempérait pas son interdiction
devenir de la cité balzac c'est pour ça
mais attention ma soeur s'était pas une
elle cherchait pas les problèmes et
c'est d'ailleurs le jour où ça s'est
produit où ils sagna la fin une raclée à
la copine
de djamel quoi est là elle a pris le
parti de 2 de sa copine en disant à
issac ce qu'il avait fait c'était pas
bien et d'ailleurs elle éviter les
problèmes elle nous en parlait même pas
de ce qui s'était passé et c'est elle on
n'a même pas parlé aïssa son petit ami
donc franchement elle était dans une
aile l'été dans un elle voulait apaiser
les choses plus qu'autre chose et en fin
de compte j'en ai pris l quand même
ouais
alors le 4 octobre 2002 dont il entraîne
swan dans le local à poubelles il ya un
copain lui qui montent la garde
et quand il ya des gens qui veulent
rentrer il ya le copain qui dit les cv
ils sont en train de parler en amoureux
quoi
et pendant ce temps jamal commence à
pourrir votre soeur il lui a dit tu t'es
bien foutus de ma gueule tu vas le
regretter
et là il lui a vidé une bouteille
d'essence sur la tête
de l'essence qu'il avait acheté chez
esso la veille
donc c'est prémédité pour moi c'est
prémédité
alors à ce moment-là il alluma un
briquet il approche le briquet dalle
donc ça peut prendre feu à n'importe
quel moment puisque ces 10 centimes à 2
7 cm pour que ça prenne feu elle elle le
supplie elle lui dit fais pas ça à lui
des banques et je reviendrai plus jamais
dans la dans la cité balzac ok pour moi
la paix et lui frime quoi il dit a peur
bah oui je sais pas ce qu'il y avait
dans sa tête
je n'arrive pas à expliquer son acte
j'arrive pas à expliquer
j'arrive pas à mettre main d'enfant
voilà à aucun moment je
n'ai pas il essaie vraiment de la
torture quoi ne serait ce que rend versé
de l'essence sur une personne comme moi
c'est où il a séquestré tout simplement
ou la forcer à aa venir à balzac pour
moi rien que ça c'est enfin rien que ça
c'est énorme mais pour moi c'est une
torture
lesdites a peur tu as peur et à ce
moment-là il approche le briquet et là
c'est un flash thermique ça fait une
énorme explosion quoi à la haye la
vallée de l'essence donc est là
l'autopsié a révélé qu'elle a je sais
pas si elle a brûlé de l'intérieur mais
ça c'est lé plus morte d'un choc et de
tous cas la vallée quoi
tout prend feu dans le local à poubelles
à ce point lui aussi d'ailleurs lui
aussi il a pris feu au niveau des mains
mais un peu je crois au visage alors
elle elle sort de ce local à poubelles
comme une torche vivante elle se dirige
vers la pelouse qui est devant
lcl s'écroule elle est brûlée à 80%
elle va mourir je crois dans les dans le
camion des pompiers mais
mais à la douleur était trois superbes
quoi
alors lui ben il prend un bus pour aller
se faire soigner à la salpêtrière sous
un faux nom où il se fera arrêter deux
jours après voilà
donc on voit bien que c'est pas un crime
accidentelle
c'est pas un crime passionnel non plus
puisqu'il y avait jamais rien eu entre
eux l'autopsié a prouvé que votre soeur
de toute façon était vierge
lui l'a dit ça il a dit qu'il l'aimait
mais s'il avait aimé il n'aurait pas
laissé brûler sur la pelouse de toute
façon ne seraient pas partis en bus
parce que
je sais pas je n'arrive pas à comprendre
l'individu qui j'ai essayé de le
comprendre mais je peux pas c'est
impossible
quand on aime une personne et crime
passionnel c'est une chose mais la part
du temps on n'arrive pas à se remettre
de la mort de son ami mais et
c'est pas moi je
dis j'ai du mal ay croire au crime
passionnel vraiment
pensé quoi le mobile du crime à votre
avis que moi c'est un règlement de
comptes
un
direct par par petite amie interposés
quoi
ce qui est incroyable c'est quand il ya
eu des reconstitutions dans le quartier
il ya des gens qui ont applaudi jamal
des rares
ouais moi je vous dis cette histoire m
échappe complètement jeu gg ya plein de
choses que je comprends pas et
y en a plein qui connaissait pas swan
donc ils ont ils ont du mal peut-être à
s'identifier à elle mais
mais je pense que
enfin c'est triste qu'on soit amené à
enfin
je sais pas il ya eu peut-être le fait
que le garçon habite et
balzac donc ya une
identification se fait plus facilement
que pour la victime mais encore une fois
c'est une jeune une gamine de 17 ans qui
a brûlé quoi et ça aurait pu être
n'importe qui en fin de compte dans ce
qu'est une solidarité entre garçons
non parce que il ya aussi des jeunes
filles qui l'ont applaudi donc on peut
pas dire
même pas ce à quoi oui mais voilà ces
jeux mais encore une fois je sais pas
tout la cité que l'applaudir ouais c'est
certaines personnes qui n'ont pas pris
conscience de ce qui s'était passé et
quoi ils connaissent pas soan donc
c'est un peu n'importe qui conte a brûlé
vous avez peur vous maintenant
moi j'ai pas peur de mourir mais j'ai
peur d'être torturés ça c'est quelque
chose qui me travaille énormément et qui
tuent m'angoisse en fait mais mourir non
on continue à habiter site est bourgogne
non j'habite plus morgane jamais pu être
ici
oui et il a fallu que ma soeur soit
brûlée vive pour que la parole commence
à se libérer
ouais parce que auparavant parlé
beaucoup du mal être des jeunes garçons
d
des jeunes garçons cité et c'est tout à
fait normal mais on a oublié que dans
ces cités il ya aussi des filles qui
peuplent ces sites est d'aider des
hommes des pères de famille des mères
qui elle aussi souffre après la
souffrance elle peut être multiple et
puis tout le monde ne souffre pas en
citer 1
il a fallu trois ans pour que
l'inscription mortes brûlés vives soient
inscrits sur la plaque commémorative
parce qu'en fait le le maire de vitry
n'est pas quoi ben ça faisait un peu de
la mauvaise publicité pour sa ville déjà
et puis bon mortes brûlés vives c'est
quand même des mots
dignes d'une autre époque
c'était très mal acceptée mais c'est pas
les mots qui tuent tic qui font souffrir
les gens à cesser les actes c'est ce qui
s'est passé qui fait vraiment souffrir
et pour que qu'on est qu'on arrive à
avancer et qu'on
banalise pas ce qui s'est passé il faut
mettre des mots sur ''le sur toute cette
souffrance tout sept sous de cette
douleur quoi faut pas masquer cacher
comme on l'a fait il faut en parler pour
que les gens l'oublient pas sur toi
alors j'ai été déçu également kahina par
l'association ni [ __ ] ni soumises vous
avez reproché un petit peu à fadela
amara sa démarche médiatique mais est ce
que l ai pas condamnés à ça finalement
écoutez moi je sais pas je sais que
cette association existe depuis plus
d'une dizaine d'années on n'en a jamais
entendu parler bon
maintenant il a fallu ce drame pour que
pour qu'elle existe quelque part pour
moi c'est de la récupération pure et
simple
maintenant si c'est de la récupération
positive tant mieux
je sais pas si c'est de la récupération
positive dans le sens où c'est pas une
association qui j'ai bien vu dans
certains quartiers quoi et
je crois que ce drame et tout ce qui
tout ce que tout ce qui est sorti de
cette histoire il faut faire quelque
chose de positive il faut comment dire
faut pas
[Applaudissements]
comment dire
aggravé les relations entre les garçons
et les filles quoi
et je sais pas si si l'association ni
[ __ ] ni soumises un riva à comment dire
unifiée
unifier les gens en citer quoi comment
ça va vous aujourd'hui
je sais pas je
culpabilise énormément parce que c'est
ma petite soeur et parce que
parce qu'elle méritait de vivre autant
que n'importe quel jalade jeunes
adolescentes et adolescents de
2 partout quoi
et bon ben j'ai faim
je crois qu'on a tous notre part de
responsabilité dans ce qui s'est passé
quoi
vous dit j'étais carriériste plein
d'ambition de rêve aujourd'hui je suis
éteinte
j'attends plus grand chose de la vie
vous allez vous reprendre j'espère
devenir journaliste à la télévision
comme claire chazal oh non ça
m'étonnerait pourquoi
wayne swan pour moi non mais c'est un
désir non qu'il ya eu neuf auquel
je sais pas ce qu'il faut quoi j'ai
envie de la retrouver quoi j'ai envie de
lui dire que
j'ai envie de sa fin j'aimerais savoir
s'il ya 6 1 6 1 enfin j'espère qu'il ya
un monde après après la vie terrestre
quoi et j'aimerais lui dire cuba
que je suis désolé de tout ce qui s'est
passé et qui est non qui tua
et que j'espère qu'elle est qu'elle est
bien oui lesquels
enfin voilà quoi
matin c'est dur vous êtes obligé de vous
faire violence pour les prendre le métro
on lui pardonnerait à jamal des rares un
jour
j'en sais rien
parce que nous a quand même brûlé
psychologiquement et nous a
torturé psychologiquement depuis depuis
quatre ans
et je sais pas si c'est ce qu'il a fait
c'est pardonnable j'essaie de
j'essaie de comprendre en quoi il peut
être pardonnable néant j'ai du mal quoi
25 ans de prison votre vexé c'est
beaucoup c'est pas assez
je sais pas je vous dis la vérité quand
j'ai entendu les 25 ans sam sam âme ça
m'a un peu délivrés dans le sens où
enfin on a reconnu qu'il était coupable
enfin il y avait une espèce de justice
qui se faisait
mais maintenant l'heure actuelle je peux
pas vous dire si c'est
si c'est juste ou si c'est pas juste âge
j'ai beaucoup de comment dire de
compassion pour tous ces parents et pour
sa famille
mais
j'espère qu'il prendra conscience un
jour qu'il a
qu'il a
qui l'a torturé une jeune fille qui lui
a absolument rien fait quoi
comment procéder donnait déjà
l'impression d'avoir pris conscience de
ce qu'ils avaient fait ou non
je sais pas je vous l'avais trouvé
arrogant arrogant non mais
non je j'avais l'impression d'avoir à la
fois un gamin en face de moi est à la
fois une personne qui qui qui voulait
sauver sa peau à tout prix
moi je suis désolé si un jour je suis
amené à faire un truc aussi odieux je
pourrais pas vivre je ne pourrais pas
vivre avec ça
j'ai pensé souvent à ce même tous les
jours
y a pas un jour où way pas dans mon
coeur il n'y a pas un jour
où je dis mais pas au début je l'imaginé
l'imaginer en train de brûler maintenant
mon bas
j'imagine sa souffrance quoi et ça c'est
quelque chose de
très difficile quoi
au privé ouais
je prie pour qu'elles ont même si elle
avait aucun péché mais je prie pour
qu'elle
quelle soit bien où elle est quoi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu